la parole est demeuré collègue françois
bonhomme pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la forêt elle porte
sur la crise de la viande bovine
après plusieurs jours de blocus des
abattoirs les éleveurs bovins en
situation de cessation de paiement ou en
voie de l'être viennent de suspendre
leur action de protestation
vous avez présidé hier une table ronde
réunissant les différents acteurs de la
filière
à l'issue de celle-ci la grande
distribution les abatteurs ont consenti
un prix revalorisé il est prévu de payer
aux producteurs 5 centimes de plus par
kilo de carcasse et d'incrémenter les
prix d'un même commentant toutes les
semaines jusqu'à ce que le prix d'achat
aux éleveurs couvre les coûts de
production autre mesure annoncée
un projet de plate forme d' aide à
l'exploitation des viandes et enfin une
clause de revoyure afin de vérifier la
réalité des engagements pris mais voilà
monsieur le ministre le rapport récent
au parlement le rapport de philippe
chalmin qui préside l'observatoire de la
formation des prix et des marges des
produits alimentaires est clair sur ce
point la baisse des prix des bovins
principal a principalement profité à la
partie aval notamment en raison de la
concentration des centrales d'achat qui
se trouve ainsi en position de force
plus généralement sur 7 euros deux
valeurs alimentaires produites 8 euros
seulement reviennent aux producteurs
c'est donc comme problème de fond vous
le savez monsieur le ministre la filière
bovine et plus largement les éleveurs ne
sont pas du genre à se plaindre et même
en autre chose à faire que de défiler ou
de mener des actions
cette désespérance des éleveurs n'est
pas qu'une simple montée de température
c'est même une crise profonde d'une
profession très fragilisée qui ne peut
accepter durablement d'être une variable
d'ajustement
j'ajoute qu'en quelques années la
filière viande bovine a subi une baisse
de 30 % des installations sans revenus
les exploitations ne peuvent plus être
transmises et empêche tout projet
professionnel pour
plus jeunes qui veulent se lancer tout
cela est d'autant plus absurde que la
france n'est pas autosuffisante à la
matière malgré une baisse de la
consommation et doit chaque année
importer des volumes un four votre
question viande pour répondre aux
besoins des consommateurs
dès lors monsieur le ministre pouvez
vous nous indiquer les mesures durables
et forte que vous entendez prendre de
nature à rétablir des prix rémunérateur
pour les producteurs et redonner un
avenir à cette filière qui participent à
notre modèle alimentaire
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
que au secrétaire d'état chargé du
commerce extérieur m mathias et que vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs et sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur françois bonhomme
permettez-moi d'abord de vous prier
d'excusés le ministre de l'agriculture
monsieur le foll qui est en ce moment
même au congrès des jeunes agriculteurs
ja jeunes agriculteurs qui sont l'avenir
de notre agriculture
hier encore de nombreux abattoirs de
viande bovine étaient bloquées et ce par
des voeux des éleveurs qui vous l'avez
rappelé font face à une situation
difficile et même très difficile
les raisons de la crise sont multiples
l'embargo russe l'arrivée sur le marché
de vaches laitières de réformes qui ont
perturbé le marché
tout cela se traduit vous l'avez indiqué
par des prix trop bas par rapport aux
coûts de production et la situation
telle qu'elle est risque de mettre en
péril l'avenir même des éleveurs et donc
de la filière or l'élevage bovin a une
importance majeure dans l'économie de
nombreux territoires et la priorité pour
l'élevage s'est traduite récemment par
les choix faits par la france dans la
mise en oeuvre de la pac
mais au delà des aides il faut donner
des perspectives économiques positives à
la filière et c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que stéphane le foll a réuni
les acteurs de la filière en mai dernier
et puis hier il a appelé l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques et en particulier
les abatteurs et les distributeurs à
faire preuve de responsabilité et hier
accord très important a été obtenu pour
une remontée progressive du prix d'achat
des animaux qui commencera dès cette
semaine et sera répercutée par tous les
maillons de la chaîne c'est bien l'enjeu
de la question
les éleveurs ont en conséquence accepté
de débloquer les abattoirs partout en
france
stéphane le foll a aussi annoncé le
doublement de l'envelope débloqués en
mai pour la prise en charge des
cotisations sociales des éleveurs la
portant à 7 millions d'euros pour
traiter des situations d'urgence en
trésorerie
au-delà des problèmes conjoncturels nous
faisons face à des difficultés
structurelles et c'est pourquoi le miso
l'agriculture a défini hier une feuille
de route pour y remédier il faut plus
grande transparence sur les prix à la
production mais aussi sur des produits
emblématiques comme le steak haché et
par ailleurs avec stéphane le foll nous
sommes mobilisés dans ce que nous avons
appelé ensemble la diplomatie des
terroirs pour à l'international et des
nôtres agric faut conclure portée et
nous avons encore récemment obtenu des
avancées notamment au vietnam suite à
mon récent déplacement
stéphane le foll moi-même tout le
gouvernement sont totalement mobilisé
aux côtés de la filière qui le mérite
bien